hey what's going on it's bill burr it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcasts in
ah I'm just checking it on yeah I'm just
checking in on you a week on to it is
[ __ ] Thursday Thursday Joad [ __ ]
payday actually I get paid on Friday
well [ __ ] you and your job I used to get
paid on Thursday
I skipped paid on Thursday and I used to
keep my money I used to have my money I
spent it on May well where do you want
to go who's it up to pay
I mean dependent she got now my life was
mine and that 260 bucks a week that I
made I had a [ __ ] car payment for
$138 a month I was rolling in it
you know [ __ ] rolling in it I didn't
even realize it I was thinking I'll gee
wouldn't it be great someday to [ __ ]
get out there in the world get my own
place have a car drive down the street
man right what happens you get out there
and you [ __ ] you're stupid you're
like a little toddler walking crawling
up to a [ __ ] Cobra and they forgot
this so its mouth shut you know like how
they do that [ __ ] over in India you know
we just born into a family of snake
charmers whatever happens over they ever
seen that video I assumed it was in
India you know and don't get mad at me
blame Hollywood all right I've hung out
with disease a few times I never I never
brought the Cobra thing up I forgot to
find out if this was true or not I could
have been like aziza is this or is this
not a your people thing specifically and
then it could have been like god no belt
is actually the snake charmers all over
all over the world you know what I would
have said what's it fair enough but I
didn't so anyways you haven't seen those
[ __ ] videos where they they show that
goddamn Cobras [ __ ] mouth shut
could I curse more in that sentence have
you seen those um have you seen that
footage
where they take the at this point with
this voice I'd have to know the Latin
name for a Cobra they sell the [ __ ]
thing just mouth shut and then they have
a baby crawl up to it and the snake is
like freaking out cuz you got to
understand as small as a baby as to a
person for a snake it's still pretty
[ __ ] big like what was what is that
is that a mongoose they're gonna run up
and just grab my face and give me a
couple of shakes and then that's it last
thing I see in my life is the inside of
a [ __ ] mongooses esophagus that's
what the snake is thinking it's just a
snake only has one [ __ ] expression
you know reptiles are like redefined
resting [ __ ] reptiles never look
like they're in a good mood or they just
stay or they just have like no they just
kind of [ __ ] sitting there like a
frog all right it's not a [ __ ]
reptiles and amphibian well whatever it
is doesn't have any hair on it they have
a little bit oh that was less cool slice
claypoole's line right I'm just talking
about some woman said she was finer than
frog hair what the [ __ ] song was that
that was one of his solo albums his
bucket of Boerne brains something of the
hunt I can't remember my brains going oh
I noticed I was talking about babies
[ __ ] messing with with cobras I don't
know how I got there
I mean what's going on how many minutes
just went by three forty two just like
that just like that 342 you drive home
and you drive to work right well maybe
you have really tiny headphones and your
wife's bitching at you rain on you
listen to this Oh your boyfriend I don't
know I don't know what the [ __ ] he's
doing yeah you had that drink that
you're gonna go out in the real world
and your money was gonna be made and it
was gonna go into your pocket and dude
I'm gonna have a [ __ ] kegerator over
here [ __ ] pool table air hockey and
what happens twenty years goes by twenty
years way to go twenty years I don't
know right Bob Seger sometimes I sit in
wonder
wait a gong possum artists Bob Seger
Bob Seger was smart enough to realize
that most people lose and he's saying
right to those [ __ ] and they showed
up with their [ __ ] one of the ones
that ol Milwaukee's right and they sat
right in the front row that bottom lips
quivering you know and then the wise
would look over like oh honey what's the
matter and then they'd have to slap
their wife because you couldn't show
that you cried back then when the song
first came out and I can sit there with
like cupcakes and kittens on your shirt
as a man sit there Indian style wearing
yoga pants and your wife you know I
don't know what she's doing she's got
work boots on and a trucker hat I don't
know what goes on with the youth today I
don't pretend to know I'm an older
person all right
all I know is somehow all the bands went
into the computer and they never came
out again and then they just became one
person you know like Mayweather says
form like Voltron right doesn't Voltron
like one guy I don't what the [ __ ] it is
Wow the hell with it I mean I'm from the
age you like I mean I was too old for
stomper four by force when they came out
that's how I played with Tonka trucks
people okay there was no batteries and
that thing you wanted it to move you had
to [ __ ] push it all right and you
rode those thing down the driveway and
right before went into traffic you
bailed off of it and you prayed to God
that it would make the other side
without getting run over by a milk truck
right there you go so in like you I also
don't know what I'm talking about at
this point anyways yeah you thought it
was gonna be all your night in 20 years
[ __ ] goes by okay and then one day
you walk a D house and you're just
looking around at all the [ __ ] and all
it really is is it's just a bunch of she
wasn't what is all this [ __ ] [ __ ]
tables and couches chair we're gonna
[ __ ] chairs here how many kids do we
plan on having why are there so many
goddamn chairs whoa this is a perfect
area right here where a drug kit could
go you know what is that stupid picture
why don't you take it off the wall put
up a [ __ ] jack I just feel like that
wouldn't look right
be kind of awkward why would that be
awkward you know what's awkward
every room vaguely looking the same we
look like we live in a furniture store
there's nothing in here but furniture
how about some fun [ __ ] what about that
game will you try to punch it as hard as
you can to see how strong you are
you know what that game where you shoot
the baskets you can't just have one of
those I don't know I just feel like that
was you know maybe in the garage is
there a way to put it behind the house
and down the street I don't want to have
a company over and have them see that
you're having fun I wanted my wife
better not listen this I want them to
come over and see that you are totally
in control under my control and you are
you are listening to the [ __ ]
decisions that I want to make I'm just
[ __ ] with you
[Music]
anyways whatever most of that isn't true
only the sad part it's Thursday
everybody either get paid today or
tomorrow what do you do with you money
huh what do you do here Bank of America
evidently their entire [ __ ] system
was down how does that happen
that's not scary enough visit Jesus
Christ I hope they didn't you know I
should look that up I should look that
up before I caused a run on a bank is
that the name of a song run on a bank is
that a Bob Seger song was it ain't no
surprise
well that's love on the rocks not run on
a bank love on the rocks ain't no big
surprise I thought it was one on a bank
grab them by their ties especially with
their milk white [ __ ] thighs why does
my internet suck in every [ __ ] room I
swear to God all of my internet company
is they have to have a poster me on the
wall go we need more customers like this
he pays ten times what he should [ __ ]
pay it never works and he never
complains unless he's doing his podcast
but who gives a [ __ ] cuz he never calls
us so what do we care we just keep
taking his [ __ ] money alright here we
go
a Bank of America
[ __ ] yeah
everyone in the world is jealous of us
everyone wants to be just like us that's
why they hate on us alright maybe maybe
we're getting out of line in a few areas
all right evidently it's loading you
know I mean watching my computer try to
get on the internet like waiting for it
for a load it's like watching me try to
remember [ __ ] from [ __ ] two days ago
oh you sneaky [ __ ] bastards this
isn't what I wanted I didn't want your
website I wanted the [ __ ] gossip
we're gonna hit Bank of America slash
TMZ bank of [ __ ] America here we go
get Bank of America Google here we go
here we go what do you got what do we
got customers shout out of accounts
during apparent Bank of America outage
oh boy oh boy I'm just picturing someone
with one of those what's that white mask
that those [ __ ] the hackers wear when
they want to shut down the corporation's
[Music]
all right here we go Bank of America
customers were shut out from their
accounts Oh an advertisement all Ralphs
Jesus you know what I will buy a honey
of a ham all right what Beck
Bank of America customers were shut up
from their accounts for several hours
Wednesday in a system outage you know
somebody's [ __ ] you know didn't get
dialysis to their heart stop see you
would the you wouldn't he was such which
was so at the feet of these [ __ ]
[ __ ] Coral Springs resident Eric's oh
he's asleep but you never think he could
run that fast in those work boots and
there he goes down the street so we got
what looked like a phishing email from
the bank Wednesday and immediately
started calling customer service to see
if something was wrong a message on his
online accounts that it could not pull
up his information when we called his
local branch a manager said that the
local management are calling each other
trying to figure out what caused what
appeared to be a national outage and why
they were unable to provide certain
services
like what provide you with the money
that you need on down to Tector calm a
website that tracks reports of system
outages reports started spiking after
11:30 a.m. and the website was inundated
with comments from bank of American
customers what the [ __ ]
send around the country saying they
couldn't access online banking computers
transited by 1:00 p.m. they had received
nearly 1000 reports of problems but by
Wednesday evening although some
customers were still reporting problems
the number reports had gone down
considerably to about 200 and then this
is their comment I know that the tape is
working quickly to bring everything back
up as time progresses they should be
able to go back online I would really
love to see what really happened Bank of
America system why system-wide outage on
the dam closing on closing on my house
and there's nothing I can do about it
Bank of America you closed my bank
account with no notice how can I deposit
my check when I no longer have an
account stuck in Thailand what is up
with not being able to transfer system
has been down for three hours well Jesus
Jenny that's nothing compared to the guy
stuck in Thailand the clerk at Bank of
America just said I can't make it to cut
deposit because the nationwide
disruption anyone know what's up all
right yeah okay all right well let's
just hope that was a one-time thing
nothing to see here that's [ __ ] scary
that's why you got to have your money in
like three different banks I don't care
if you got 40 bucks put 15 110 and
another where we got left and what's
that 25 you got 15 in the last one right
15 15 and 10 it's a [ __ ] shell game
out there man then when you got to pay
your rent you write three different
checks in why don't you just write it
for the full amount because I'm not
gonna get stuck in Thailand you [ __ ]
what do you care as long as it all works
all right let's get back to the podcast
here I am when when you listen to this I
will be in New York City by the time you
listen to this I am going to the airport
to not
not to that I'm going back to New York
for about a week I'm gonna be there for
a week week doing an acting gig out
there as I mentioned before they're
rebooting Sex in the City and I'm gonna
be playing this Cynthia Nixon character
they said to keep my head shaved maybe
they could do some sort of I don't know
post you know cancer-free
I guess Craig Nixon I don't know what my
[ __ ] names gonna be but you know I
wanted to be the the fabulous one
whatever [ __ ] her name is what the [ __ ]
was her name
I saw one time at a Knicks game she
looks still look beautiful you know with
her thin [ __ ] head what thing you
know she needs more head and I need less
head if we could somehow combine the two
of us I think you know they could have
something there the [ __ ] is her name she
started it how do you remember Cynthia
Nixon and you all remember the other one
Sarah Jessica Parker that's right
SJP she had a [ __ ] basketball shoe
how about those Red Sox one in the last
three out of four you know I did you
like that [ __ ] went two and two against
the [ __ ] Yankees over there and we
took two out of three from the Blue Jays
I watched the whole Blue Jays series I
enjoy you what's great is Dennis
Eckersley up in the booth the man loves
the game the man played the game the man
could talk the game goddammit he does it
for nine innings I love especially once
like a low-scoring game if you have a
[ __ ] picture up there he's incredible
it'll actually make it exciting I think
he's gonna kill me with the [ __ ] like
breaking ball here guy throws a breaking
boys I get this guy he's like it's a he
has [ __ ] ESP it's like he pitched in
the [ __ ] league everybody how does
this man know what happens evidently the
Yankees made some sort of move to
cock-block the Red Sox but you know I
try to get annoyed by that but you know
it's been three World Series I think
we're good gives a [ __ ] we're in first
place I think it's kind of over I think
the Yankees Red Sox thing is it'll never
be what it was and I'm happy for it I'm
actually glad that it won't be
I don't miss it because you know it
usually didn't work out for it worked
out for us once and that was over
anyways oh by the way I still have
posted a picture my drumkit I swear to
you no I'm gonna [ __ ] send it right
now so I'm gonna send it right [ __ ]
now you probably already see it by the
time this thing's posted
let me just [ __ ] it's not the
greatest picture I was by myself what do
you want from me come on oh [ __ ] you
know I was reading something the other
day I'm gonna get to it
about Goodfellas it was this really cool
thing that said thirty things you might
not know about Goodfellas and there's
actually thirty things I didn't [ __ ]
know even though they still talked about
how how am i funny what do I amuse you
what am i some sort of clown everybody
knows that there was improv but like
Pesci those guys were saying we would
improv it and then he he would write it
all down and then you know take the best
parts and then write it down then he had
to memorize it then you'd [ __ ] go do
it which makes sense because you can't
like [ __ ] improv every different take
and then he moves the cameras around you
saying different [ __ ] that you did the
other time and then it's not it's not
gonna line up so anyways he was his it
was the best one of the best ones that
whole tracking scene where Henry Hill
takes Karen what did you do right he
takes her in through the kitchen right
the whole track is shot and that was one
sentence in the book that Scorsese got
this idea there's a there's a line in
that book wiseguy or whatever the [ __ ]
the one that Henry Hill wrote it said
uncrowded nights when people were lined
up outside and couldn't get in the
doorman used to let Henry I'm sorry the
prints really small my eyes are going
used to let Henry and our party in
through the kitchen which was filled
with Chinese cooked and we go upstairs
and sit down immediately that one
sentence in that poll [ __ ] book I
mean how many times did you read that
book he did
right at one time and said oh that gives
me an idea BAM you think it would least
be a paragraph some sort of story
attached to it it's just one goddamn
sentence and that guy's [ __ ] able to
do all of that and that my friends is
why he's one of the great directors of
all time alright let's let's get a good
one here let's get a good one oh there
we go
there we go symbols were a [ __ ] up
angle I had to run out of there I'm a
dad now it's like whenever I get a
[ __ ] chance I run over there I ran
over there this morning I literally
played four songs and then went to work
I didn't stretch at all
because I didn't have time to and then
my [ __ ] forearms and hands were all
[ __ ] up I'm an idiot all right let me
pretend this right now you guys are
literally listening to me send a [ __ ]
picture that the Oh guess who wants to
come back guess who wants to come back
after after [ __ ] dumped in this
podcast guess who wants to come back huh
after it's not nature's box
it's a hold on second post this with
podcast you can't I didn't say that
alright guess going
draftkings wants to come back wait up
[ __ ] did they go huh what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you
did you hear what's-his-face goddamn
they're gonna be back by the way
cuz they said I can say whatever the
[ __ ] I want you means I can make the
advertisement as funny as I watch it
means you guys will listen and there you
go that's all that's all advertising is
just get people to listen and maybe
somebody will buy there was a rumor that
[Music]
what's-his-face Clara Connor microRNA
McGregor got knocked out by his sparring
partner and I looked it up and what I
loved was Mayweather it's like I don't
believe it until I see footage I don't
believe it like maybe that was a
strategy by my grad
and it kind of all got [ __ ] just
explained away like no it didn't happen
so there you go there's one for you guys
who are still gonna order it there is no
proof it was debunked by the McGregor
Camp Mayweather wouldn't that does not
believe it so there's still a chance
there's some stupid article out there
calling Conor McGregor yet another great
white hope it's like this is not another
great white hope great white hope would
be if he was an actual in boxing trying
to win a [ __ ] title you know this guy
holds two titles he already is a
champion okay he already is a champion
you know and it's not a whites only
league so I don't know how he's a great
weight oh this is a [ __ ] spectacle
that's what this is - goddamn spectacle
I am gonna try so [ __ ] hard not to
order it I already agreed with Rogan
that I might watch it the next week with
them he does this thing where you've
just [ __ ] watch it together and you
talk about it I might do that with Rogan
if I could find some goddamn time to do
it I have to do it that's also a good
way to watch it for free for free
[Music]
maybe that's what do I'll be the [ __ ]
grumpy guy that didn't watch it and then
also already will watch it and really
just a tight [ __ ] I'm gonna watch it for
free
I remember that expression [ __ ] ante
up yet tight [ __ ] hey does anybody know
how the expression on the arm came about
we're trying to figure that out today in
the writers room meaning it's for free
the best I could get is that it's it's a
policemen slang on the arm and all I
could think was you know the long arm of
the law the arm of the law why is why
how does the expression on the arm come
about what is the origin that means it's
free don't pay for these drinks there on
the arm can anybody tell me cuz people
already told me P's and Q's mind your
own P's and Q's came from the bars and
the pubs where they used to give beer in
pints and quarts so when people got a
little you know out of line and sticking
their nose in other people's business or
getting ready to fight AAA
mind your P's and Q's
you'll look at your [ __ ] glass you
don't look at anybody else so whatever
the [ __ ] it meant right so I like that
[ __ ] so if you can tell me how long the
arm came about I'll give a [ __ ] if you
make up stuff I'll read it like it's
it's a fact then it'll end up on
Wikipedia and then at least people will
have an answer anyway so these [ __ ]
Toronto Blue Jay fans were talking [ __ ]
cuz I actually watched that whole
[ __ ] 14 inning game where Hanley
Ramirez hit the walk-off home run right
it was 3 3 after regulation and then 13
after nine inning sort of the [ __ ] you
say in the sport and then in like the
12th inning or something like that Blue
Jays scored a run went up four to three
and then we somehow scored a run made it
4 to 4 and then Hanley Ramirez in the
bottom of the 14th hit a walk-off crush
to hang in curveball out onto the
[ __ ] mass pipe there and I loved
Eckersley he was saying he was saying
that Hanley's going I love you I love
cuz he just we just wants to go home
[ __ ] hilarious
especially because we're that nineteen
in a game with the Yankees a few days
earlier but oh Jesus what the [ __ ] was I
talking about
I literally just forgot everything I was
talking about there was a point I was
trying to make there on the arm then to
the Red Sox and then [ __ ] out my ear
down my pant leg and I don't know where
the [ __ ] it went I don't know what the
[ __ ] I was talking about there oh I know
it's talking [ __ ] well I didn't talk
[ __ ] these [ __ ] blue jay fans are
giving me [ __ ] so I don't know where
this [ __ ] drum company cymbal making
company I never heard of before called
dream symbols I don't know where it
starts talking [ __ ] go neg if I figure
out the rents that the Red Sox win a
thread Sox win we'll give you a free bag
of symbols if the Blue Jays win you know
you got to give us free advertising so
the Red Sox went there like a [ __ ] it
what kind of symbols do you want or
whether if they were even serious I was
just like you know gonna be a bag of
[ __ ] symbols I already have symbols I
can't play the cymbals I have why would
I take a bag of yours that you could
actually sell to someone who knows how
to play drums so just for the [ __ ] of it
I'm gonna you know
I'm going to start the advertising with
a free read I've never heard of these
guys dream symbols dream symbols though
relatively new on the market dream
symbols and gongs produced world-class
handmade produces world-class handmade
symbols out of a factory in China's Han
region am I gonna be put on a watch list
I didn't know you I thought we were the
enemy which has crafted excellent gongs
for generations for drummers searching
for their own style dream is a dream
come true
each symbol has its own unique voice
enhancing musicians distinct in this
dreams I actually listen to Gus a couple
of people play the cymbals they sound
pretty good you know and I would imagine
cuz their lesser-known aka nuts iljin
not Zildjian not Sabian that [ __ ]
paste or Paiste over the [ __ ] you say it
my know all the kids play mile now
everybody's got to play the miles you
want to be different
why don't you play dream symbols oh
don't I don't give a [ __ ] they're not
paying me you can buy the set of these
symbols and roll them down the [ __ ]
hill for all I give a [ __ ] all right now
into the real stuff all right that was
just a warm-up
people start doing that free advertising
just a warm up I apologize from making a
lot of noise I got a cough drop him
[ __ ] my boss oh who is it oh look
who's here hey sweetheart
my daughter's walking she's already
knocking on doors guess who learned how
to crawl she crawls like an inchworm now
you don't care about your toys though do
you
I love his new shy thing she does what
she sees and she looks away yeah what's
up buddy you gonna hang out watch
another 40 names a Red Sox baseball with
me tonight
you actually already went okay all right
it's hot as hell in here
turn it on if you don't mind bye hey Nia
what would you do if somebody had that
level of bad breath I read that thing to
you
halitosis and literally had like that
[ __ ] slime along the gumline there's
no way you're kissing him right would
you say anything you know I mean if you
really really likes her like damn I
could really see myself with this girl
then you say some how do you see past
you know what I could think of all I
could think of was when you know when
they just the day when they just empty
the dumpster and you look inside of it
and all that [ __ ] that liquid slime
that's all I could thought that poor
with their dental hygiene I feel like
that definitely is a red flag
to be honest yeah you're not going
downstairs you've seen the Attic yeah
and I don't want to see the basement I
know she's so cute
all right turn the a/c don't mine it
bugged me last night by the way you all
impressed that I got to go to sleep it
bug me I know I I didn't know ya didn't
know I had a difficulties getting her to
go to sleep oh that just means I don't
want to do it I can do it I just don't
want to do it I just knew it was easier
I know I just know is easier for you to
do it because you know you can always
tap out it's like drunk drivers with
ubers you can always take your boob out
and then put her to sleep with that I
can't do that okay I'm a man without a
country there but now I'm realizing
you're just
so lazy I worked all day in a writers
room staring at a computer screen trying
to think of jokes for animated children
all right just for that I'm drinking
tonight and I'm gonna be really
belligerent extra belligerent tonight I
know she's adorable and you know what
adorable is not funny so you see what
she does
see how she yells at me could you put
the AC on please sweetheart one thing
for you all right put the AC on don't
don't
Wow all right you could have got me
worse you could have got me worse um all
right passionate women hit hard huh
Dunphy never noticed that you date some
chick who it says no direction she balls
her fist up I mean you can literally
just continue eating your club sandwich
but if he gets a woman with passion that
or if they had an older brother it's
gonna [ __ ] hurt a little bit all
right
audibles dr. Katz dr. Katz is this the
comedian dr. Kent Jonathan Katz
I used to open for this guy way back in
the day when I started out he's [ __ ]
hilarious genius dr. Katz the
audiophiles is the new comedy series
free now at audible.com dr. Katz a cult
classic TV comedy is black is back sorry
those are black comedies be back as a
premium podcast with the original cast
at audible.com slash dr. Katz ah Jesus
Christ Jonathan if you listen this I
want to do an episode eavesdropped calm
Oh you drop on top comics on couch with
Hollywood's favorite shrink Sarah
Silverman Ted Danson Ray Romano Weird Al
Yankovic Kristen Schaal Maria Bamford
Paul F Tompkins that's how [ __ ] look at
that that's all a listers right there
some guy named Jon Hamm and somebody
named the [ __ ] is that
he said I got like half the copy it says
some somebody named more than that's it
comedians finally get the therapy they
need and you get free antidepressants in
your ear on dr. Katz the audio files
exclusively now at audible.com slash dr.
Katz all that's awesome oh look who's
back oh [ __ ] my Toto biondi's me on DS
I've been watching the [ __ ] socks
dudududu biondi's Biondi he's nice and
sew up on my [ __ ] and my balls and my
[ __ ] tate goes around in my ass I
always say ain't ow I [ __ ] it up but
who gives a [ __ ] [ __ ] squat non-dream
symbols and it doesn't hurt
alright the undies the undies are the
softest most comfortable underwear
you'll ever wear period in summer is the
perfect time to figure out how little
your balls are gonna sweat while you
upgrade your underwear drawer because
everyone is thinking about looking good
and feeling good and the undies are the
ultimate feel-good undies every pair of
the undies is sustainably sourced and
made from micro motile modal a fabric
softer three times far softer than
cotton because me undies calm I got to
get glasses man because me undies come
in all kinds of colors and patterns and
they release new limited-edition
patterns each month that always sell out
this month's pattern we're designed by
legendary 80s clothing brand cross
colors with names that live up to their
bold design and bright colors increase
DP s-- shouldn't be dub piece there's
another one called yet dig that's for
people to achieve balls and the OG now
Jesus granddad with his balls hanging
down that's what every spandex to hold
everything together
you got to see em for yourself right now
you'll say 20% off your first pair and
receive free shipping only at neon esau
comp slash burn if you don't love your
first pair of me undies they're free get
20% off your first pair plus free
shipping
the undies dot-com / / that's manis comm
/ / me honey stop calm / / two more two
more two more all right lift lift man
lift knows that their drivers are what
keep them moving so they do everything
they can to make sure that drivers are
happy on every trip lift is the
ride-sharing company that believes in
treating its people better lifts believe
I love this [ __ ] I love this Hatfield
and McCoy thing that's going on with
them and that other company that rhymes
with müber yeah I'm when I read this
copy what I learned from lyft is that if
you drive for that other company that
rhymes with Boober
they evidently treat you like [ __ ] you
don't get tipped or something on what
the [ __ ] happens but they're totally
good oh yeah this is the place this is
the ride-sharing app that gives a [ __ ]
about their drivers look there's a
ride-sharing company that believes in
treating its people better lyft believes
that being a ride-sharing drivers should
be fun if you're having a good time so
are the passengers well yeah not if
you're partying you know don't have too
much fun up there buddy okay my life
ends there if you're choosing a
ride-sharing company to drive for go
with the company that treats you better
like lift lift was the first to offer an
in-app tap tipping when you drive when
you drive for lyft you'll keep 100% of
the tips drivers have been paid over 200
million dollars in tips since the
feature was introduced lyft has even
taking the guesswork out of pickups the
new amp device uses color coding to help
passengers find the drivers you can earn
hundreds of dollars a week plus tips
want to earn more money drive more it's
never been easier to give yourself
I'll Drive more it's never been easier
to give yourself a raise that's all you
got to do is work more well that's kind
of every job works isn't it unless you
want salary it's a simple formula happy
drivers mean happy passengers maybe
that's why nine out of ten lift rides
get a perfect five star rating go to
lift calm / burger today and get your
$500 new driver bonus that's lift calm /
/ lift calm / / I don't know why I just
thought this but I don't think Ferraris
gonna catch Mercedes I just don't I
don't know what the [ __ ] going
over there I know this season is only
halfway over but I don't know
both Ferraris both [ __ ] left front
tires both in the final five laps and
it's like a bad [ __ ] sitcom I'm sorry
with all the [ __ ] mealy-mouthed on
this podcast I'm trying not to do it on
the mic it's just I got this hauls in my
mouth because my [ __ ] voice is shot
once again and I got all this acting to
do so I'm taking a break
a momentary hiatus from screaming my
jokes on stage you know I just really
need to do I need to brake smarter jokes
did all I got to do is just come out
same wear a suit bing-bang-boom
and I'm done all right simply safe
summer is prime time for burglary those
[ __ ] [ __ ] why can't they do it in
the winter when you're already miserable
you know if you having a good time I
think I feel I think she's the one
summer's prime time for burglary so now
is the time to protect your home for a
limited time you can take a whopping
$100 off simply save some special summer
package that it simply saves
biggest-ever summer sale it has
everything you need to protect your home
an arsenal of security sensors to secure
each door and window your simply save
system comes with a panic button a
blaring extra siren and a wireless
connection to authorities and police
dispatch just don't leave it in your bed
so when you roll over and you're
sleeping and wake up with three good
cops with that gun in your face yeah I
swear to god I live here your family
your home and everything in it stay safe
around the clock was simply safe there
are no long term contracts no
installation costs and no hidden fees
and 24/7 professional monitoring it's
just $14.99 a month for a panic button
how many seek Jodie Foster plateful paid
for that [ __ ] panic room I'm what an
idiot she had the whole room all you
needed was a button once you pressed
that the attackers gonna be like ah [ __ ]
and he's gonna leave you press the
button right call to action get a
hundred dollars off the summer security
package and simply say
dot-com / bar now simply safer calm now
the sale ends July 31st that simply safe
bird calm to get $100 off simply safe
dot-com simply safe bird calm [ __ ] all
right I'm just gonna swallow this
[ __ ] thing now there we go all right
sorry thirty-three [ __ ] minutes of me
[ __ ] sloshing around here 37 38
minutes alright so anyways I'm going to
be in New York sweat my balls off for
the next [ __ ] week being the new
Cynthia Nixon and you know what kills me
is I just found out too late that Guns &
Roses is going to be playing at the
Apollo Theater that night the 30th
anniversary 30th anniversary of the
Appetite for Destruction they're gonna
be doing it there I I [ __ ] could have
figured out a way to weasel my way into
that show it's done through Sirius XM
God knows I've done enough [ __ ] over
there and I completely [ __ ] myself
because I didn't realize that show was
going on and then I'm gonna be in New
York and while I'm in New York John
[ __ ] me with the night game opening
up with Davey LeSean drums at the LA
forum Steve Jordan on drums two of my
favorite drummers of all [ __ ] time
two incredible [ __ ] bands one of the
best venues to see a goddamn concert and
I show up like a [ __ ] day or two
later and I missed that you know I just
feel like I missed everything anyways
that's the podcast thank you guys so
much for listening I hope you have a
wonderful weekend you [ __ ] yeah that's
it listen to this music as we transfer
to another half hour of free [ __ ] here
from a Thursday afternoon podcast from a
Thursday gun buy in a year that already
happened or maybe it's earlier this year
I don't know I don't choose them that's
it I'll talk to you on Monday
I am a 28 year old college guy who has
it was a Jaina phobia the fear of women
I've never heard of this he said when I
was a kid I used to get the [ __ ] kicked
out of me and girls would always spread
rumors about me and it would really
screw with my mind wait a minute you
didn't get along with men or women well
what what were you doing you know what
that's the last thing you needed to hear
well what's wrong with you I'm sorry
forgive me I'm not a trained
professional so you know you're asking
them [ __ ] and you know I'm gonna behave
accordingly here we go as I grew up I
started to resent and hate all the
people around me that my mother tells me
about false rape accusations and that
makes oh and that makes females look
even more scarier than they already were
see guys just kick the [ __ ] out of you
females psychologically [ __ ] you up bad
and don't even have a tint of remorse or
empathy Jesus Christ all right dude so
your mother's a psycho she put all these
fears on you yeah you got a maybe I
would seek some professional help before
you turn into Norman Bates all right
let's continue this then I hear about
all the women raping men in the divorce
courts and in general adding more fuel
to the fear dude yeah you're
overthinking this [ __ ] I mean you
probably heard half of that from me but
I'm an idiot
don't listen to me he says gotten to the
point where when a female introduces
herself to me I just see her as a
potential mind raping and prolonged
exercise of getting verbally abused so I
just always say sorry but I have
somewhere to be right now goodbye and I
walk away sir can I steal that from you
I want to use that next time I get
pulled over yeah that license Reza Cerie
let I have someone to be right now
goodbye and you just just act like the
Rain Man and they'll [ __ ] leave you
alone that's actually brilliant
he said they scare me so much but I'm
still attracted to them oh my
god dude you listen you got a you got a
you got to get past this hopefully
you're still young and this is early on
but this is something where you are you
know everybody is trying to go towards
the we'll just call it whatever planet
live happily ever after but if you're
off by just one degree you're not really
gonna notice when you're 22 24 you know
but by the time you're 40 you're gonna
be about a million miles off course so
let's try to get you some help I will go
see a therapist sir and I know I've been
joking around but I kind of have to do
that because this is a podcast but well
actually because it's a podcast that's
supposed to be funny not saying you
can't have a serious podcast yeah I
would go get some help
quickly and I would get rid of all those
fears and I would say a lot of the fears
were probably put into your head by your
mom when you're really young and you
need to try to get those out of there
before they take any more route than
they already do already have well let's
finish here he said my mind says stay
the [ __ ] away while my dick says do it
do it [ __ ] do it
but in this climate of unrestrained
female hi-po agents and what the [ __ ] I
mean this [ __ ] that makes women invade
male spaces and makes them change
everything to suit them dude dude you're
taking your [ __ ] fear of women you
met you you're blowing by me
listen are you a great guy if you're a
great guy there's a great woman out
there for you and then and it's a
beautiful thing they're not all like
this what you're doing is you're taking
the worst of the worst of females and
you're painting it with the broad brush
all right
Jesus Christ I'm relating to this guy
here he said I'd rather stay celibate
for life all right now I don't really to
that I am a loner to a vast degree but I
got a loving family to back me up so I
ain't on the fringe or anything I plan
on just working towards my career in it
did I write this like 20 years ago Jesus
Christ plan on just working towards my
career in education but either way I'll
have to deal with women and it's been
hard to do since lately too so lately
since
my social skills tanked over the last
nine months trauma conga line of
horrific events happened and I am
working on getting the confidence back
through Brazilian Jujitsu I already lost
11 pounds and I'm starting to feel a lot
better
all right well just don't go choke out
any women all right try to put them in
the Triangle
he said anyways is there any way but
martial arts are a great way to build
self-esteem from what I've heard anyways
is there any way is there any way to get
rid of the insane fear I have about
women or is it just 15 years of hurt
that'll take almost forever and undo
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself six ways
from Sunday and good luck with your
stand-up all right
Oh see you're only 15 is that what
you're saying all right dude first of
all it's great you took up Brazilian
Jujitsu you should know how to defend
yourself and don't be a [ __ ] about it
when you become a black belt use it to
save nerds and protect yourself but
never be a bully and then as far as
women I would actually try and talk to
somebody about this and I would try to
have more of an open mind because right
now if you're only 15 years old or even
if you're young in your early 20s mid
20s
you're basically you got the lottery
pick as far as women goes all right
they're all available all first-round
draft picks bunch of first-round draft
picks just sitting there and you know
depending on when you open your mouth
and start talking to one is when you
pick in the draft if you know what I
mean sooner rather than later but I
would just talk to somebody about about
about some of your issues maybe at
school they got some free [ __ ]
therapy or something like that if you're
too young to pay for it but I don't know
I would talk to something I would talk
to some of your guy friends about it I
would you know what I would do I would
openly talk about your fear of women to
to friends you know and I would I would
sit down with your mother and just say
listen I have major issues with women
right now and I think some of it stems
from a lot of the negative things that
you've said about them and I need you to
stop
doing that because it's it's [ __ ]
with me don't don't say that part but
say it in a nicer way but if she's you
know I don't know that's the hardest
[ __ ] thing is because you are born
into the religion of your parents you
know and into all of their beliefs and
hopefully they have more good than bad
but they're human so they're gonna be
wrong and you know when you're a little
toddler all the way through like seven
eight years old your parents are godlike
you just think they know everything and
they have all the answers they never
look unsure you do everything that they
[ __ ] say so a lot of that stuff just
really takes deep root like it's it's
law in your head and then in your
teenage years you start breaking away
you realize some of his [ __ ] and
let's when some anger can come out and
that type of stuff so I would say what
you're going through is normal it's just
that you maybe had an extreme helping of
some [ __ ] anti-woman [ __ ] which I can
relate to cuz I did too and I had to
fight through that [ __ ] I mean it took
money get marry tell us 45 I had made
your [ __ ] issues but uh it's like
anything look it just use the martial
arts thing as a metaphor or a simile
whatever the [ __ ] you're supposed to
whatever the right terminology is look
you you did that you stuck with that you
lost 11 pounds you work towards that
look at look at what you're getting
you're getting positive results and it
hasn't been easy
right but you keep showing up you get
positive results I would do the same
thing with your women issues I would
just start working on it
you know next time a woman comes up and
says hello don't say I have somewhere to
go just say hello back and stay in the
conversation for as long as you can and
when you feel like bailing just say
listen I'm really shy around women and
it's something that I'm trying to work
on just put it out there and you know
what I guarantee 80% of them are gonna
say oh you know when they do that
they're gonna love it and next thing you
know you're out there watching a
romantic comedy with some lady having a
good time but I would I would address it
later I'm telling you dude it's
literally it's you think it's a mountain
it's it's a [ __ ] it's stepping up
onto the curb it's all in your head and
that's totally normal because I would
guess that your fear started when you
were in your my mom's godlike phase of
your life so you think you think it's
hey what's that [ __ ] never everest
and it is running podcasts little
[ __ ] anthill and all riken's I
believe in you there you go it's gonna
be xx right now wait a minute 1
September here god damn it
it is xx the [ __ ] odds of that um
anyways what's going on it's Bill burr
the Monday morning podcast for Monday
July the 20th and I'm actually doing it
Sunday night because whenever you listen
to this [ __ ] thing probably out
golfing yes
believe it or not a guy who already has
too many goddamn hobbies with his
pathetic drumming and guitar playing
I've I don't know I've somehow got
sucked into that game fighting it
fighting it my entire adult life all my
friends not all my friends just a bunch
of [ __ ] people I know they date day
golf and I always viewed it like
drinking coffee I just didn't like I
don't I just didn't look like that much
fun but everyone was completely addicted
to it you know I took a sip of [ __ ]
coffee when I was like eight years old
and it tasted like [ __ ] tasted like
dirty water and it looked like dirty
water and that's what it tasted like and
I never I never got into it and then
around my whole adult life I just watch
all these people walking around they
can't start their [ __ ] day unless
they get a cup of this [ __ ] you know all
these people talking about people on
crystal meth and addicted to alcohol and
[ __ ] like that I mean I guess they're
not [ __ ] slurring their speech you
know it doesn't cause him to slap
[ __ ] wife around or something like
that so I guess it's kind of harmless
but I don't know remember this kid when
I worked in a warehouse he used to drink
like [ __ ] eight cokes a day you know
he'd like suck down like one an hour
when we were working and one day he
decided to try to quit it cold turkey
and this kid couldn't even function he
had like this migraine headache he
lasted like an hour and a half maybe two
hours we wrap until our first break and
he just finally he drank a coke and he
just felt better so yeah so I avoided
that [ __ ] and I don't have been kind of
worried about losing my memory and
somebody told me if you actually drink
caffeine that actually helps with
Alzheimer's so I had an Italian meal a
few weeks ago and I drank a shot at my
spresso or espresso ever the [ __ ] you
say it and I don't know laughs I know I
know it's [ __ ] brutal I got it over
with though and then someone's like no
no no I actually read where it adds to
Alzheimer and Alzheimer's disease and I
was like you know what I don't give a
[ __ ] you know none of you were doctors
who were giving me this advice you know
it's [ __ ] ridiculous he might not
like you how many times have you done
that you know you're just sitting in a
bar and somebody just says that well
actually caffeine helps helps against
helps prevent Alzheimer's yeah they've
done studies oh really really do you
have any of those studies in front of
you what the [ __ ] do you do how what are
you what do you what do you what does
anybody do anymore huh what do you do
why are you sitting a [ __ ] cubicle
looking at spreadsheets of the sweatshop
labor this how [ __ ] up this country is
right now as far as like I'm really just
trying to buy american-made [ __ ] I
actually went and I got a couch and I
went to this this furniture store over
here in the valley and it was you know
allegedly american-made [ __ ] so I
ordered this couch because you know
you'd only take the one that's on the
floor that everybody's [ __ ] plot down
on so I get this couch right so I'm like
when I asked before I bought the couch
you know because I want to buy
american-made [ __ ] made by Americans you
know what I mean get this [ __ ]
country going again
well like we can't make a couch you know
we've made the best-looking [ __ ] cars
of all goddamn time before we started
being cheap [ __ ] about it all
right we went to the moon and we faked
going the moon I don't know what the
[ __ ] we did okay but it was it was
impressive we can make a goddamn couch
okay so I asked the guy where's the
couch made
he says it's made in Pasadena long story
short is I have a problem I end up
having a problem with the upholstery
that they put on the [ __ ] thing so
that was when I actually you know I had
to send the stupid couch back I actually
learned of their process this is what
they do they do make the couch in
Pasadena they build the damn thing but
when they put the upholstery on it they
actually that part of the job they
shipped it down to like Honduras okay
think about that they build it in
Pasadena I live over here in LA all
right and they [ __ ] ship it to
Honduras to have the the what if the
upholstery put on it and then they ship
it back to America so my thing is like
how [ __ ] cheap is the goddamn labor
down there that that's that that's
financially a better way to go you know
the [ __ ] of my up talking about golf
here I'm talking about [ __ ] shipping
couches to Honduras I don't know it's
late at night here and I'm trying not to
[ __ ] scream and yell because cuz my
neighbors are sleeping here
yes when anyway so I've taken up golf
and I still refuse to take it seriously
although I did go out and buy a little
Tiger Woods outfit you know I don't know
I said I want to go down there looking
like a douche you know like the frat boy
I figure if I dress nicely even if I
suck maybe I look like you know I'm
having a bad day or something so anyways
I'm golfing right now that's what the
[ __ ] I'm doing and I missed that whole
British Open yesterday where uh Tom
Watson Tom Watson I thought the guy was
like dead you know even though arm
Palmer is still alive this [ __ ] guy
is like 59 years old he almost won the
British
open but then he didn't which is typical
of golf oh my god something's great
greats gonna happen and then it doesn't
and then you watch somebody choke in
front of their entire family I still
haven't gotten over the math masters you
know even though uh with the Kenny Perry
he said his name he's one another he
once said I don't know what the [ __ ] he
won but you can get a green jacket I can
tell you that you can [ __ ] tell you
that what am I talking about this week
hey this is the deal alright you know
what's the deal cuz I started this
sentence off with hey just trying to get
your attention there I'm gonna be at the
The Comedy Works in Denver Colorado on
Thursday Friday and Saturday of this
week it's one of my favorite clubs out
there and I also want to thank everybody
who came out to see my show a week ago
at the punchline I had a great time as
the first time I was on stage headlining
since the middle of May because I was
being a little fancy [ __ ] dude
there's Jimmy Norton says making a movie
or sitting around waiting to do my
eleven lines however the [ __ ] you want
to look at it but I'm gonna say it in
the positive way I was making a movie
and I was a little rusty kind of found
my I was little little uh it's a little
messy but uh I got through it but I was
by the second show I was back on my game
so I'm really looking forward to this
and if you guys haven't been listening
to my podcast I am gonna be doing
another special and it looks like it's
going to be in December and it looks
like if everything works out I'm gonna
be taping it in San Francisco so I am
going to be in a theater or a comedy
club near you from here till then from
right now until then did I say that
correctly I kind of have a bit of a
starts getting going basically right at
the end of August and I'm just hardcore
September October November and half of
December and then I'm gonna take the
thing I am gonna be hardcore on the road
like the old days when I wasn't making
any money so I had to go out like three
four times a [ __ ] month and then do a
bunch of spots in the city I'm gonna be
doing it like that and I'm looking
forward to it I'm going to
try to eat healthy on the road these are
my goals now am I gonna do it who them
who the [ __ ] knows all right I'm gonna
try not to drink when I'm on the road
I'm gonna try to do some yoga I'm gonna
try to [ __ ] do some cardio do some
pull-ups get myself in shape physically
and not look like a bloated jackass
that's the last thing you want to
[ __ ] do you don't want to sweat and
you want to look like a bloated jackass
during your special and and then thirdly
you want to be [ __ ] hilarious but
that that is the that is the order
number one you do not want to sweat you
eat your balls it's no big deal
they'll throw some laughter in there
maybe they'll sweeten it up but maybe
they'll just play it once and people
forget about it but if you're pouring
[ __ ] sweat people people remember
that [ __ ] you know now why would you
know you don't [ __ ] you don't do
stand-up all right I'm a little out of
it here all right what do we got here
let's get on with the questions here oh
and if you knew my podcast welcome I
joke every week that I only have like 14
listeners but I got a mid I was at the
when I was at the punchline on Monday
punchline in San Francisco somebody
somebody yelled out Pau Gasol because
they wanted to see my impression as I
was talking about I did one here on the
podcast so before I just launched into
what I asked the people in the crowd hey
how many you guys listen to my podcast
and it was literally like 3/4 of the
crowd so I was kind of blown away by
that so I think I might be up to about
27 listeners they're people anyway so
let's get on with the podcast here I
last week I was talking about all the
celebrities who died and and how all
these morons when Ed McMahon died and
then Farrah died and then Michael
Jackson died people what do they say oh
there you go you know bad things come in
threes you know you're [ __ ] combing
trees and then Billy Mays dies right and
then [ __ ] what's-his-face [ __ ]
died earlier that month jerking off he
dies right so that's five so you know
what some [ __ ] jackass sends me this
email he was half joking
he goes you know he goes I'm one of
those guys who actually says all the
time that bad things come in threes and
I actually put up on my facebook when
those three celebrities dies when they
died I wrote bad things come in three
but then he mentioned that Karl Malden
died he goes so technically that's six
so that's three and three so I am right
really that why isn't bet why isn't it
bad things come in six you people are
right with that bad things coming
through you guys you're out of your
[ __ ] minds bad things come in threes
so then what if somebody else dies and
it goes up to seven then you keep your
[ __ ] mouth shut until two more people
die and you guys see you there there you
go
comes back around again so you guys just
basically you basically open your mouth
when whatever bad [ __ ] has been
happening is divisible by three to prove
your [ __ ] point you know that I could
say bad things come in eight and just
wait for the eighth bad thing to [ __ ]
happen and then rattle them off they
don't come in three bad things just
continue to [ __ ] happen which is why
they have ice cream and alcohol you know
so you can do fun [ __ ] while you wait
for the neck the next bad thing to
happen you know we've had a heatwave out
here there that's seven bad [ __ ]
things how are you a [ __ ] old lady
what kind of a [ __ ] human what kind
of a man says that [ __ ] um alright let's
move on to some other stuff I know that
guy was just joking the guy who sent me
the email and six but you know if I
don't take it seriously then I don't get
emotional about it and then the podcast
isn't funny alright and then I lose a
listener like that one woman from a
[ __ ] couple months ago I never heard
from her again or her alleged friends
who were listening so anyways
which really affected the overall value
of this podcast because I'm actually
doing this to get to a certain number
and then I'm gonna go corporate and then
I'm gonna sell it
just like these [ __ ] [ __ ] who start
the myspace these these social social
networks whatever the [ __ ] you call them
what they really are is they're
basically clubs on the internet you know
like I've never believed in
not I was never into the club scene I
know it's hard to believe that I didn't
put on cologne and go alright maybe I
did it a couple of times but I failed so
horrific ly and I've always said one of
my strengths in life is I've known what
I sucked at ok and going to the night at
the Roxbury things is not something I
was never good at excuse me I need to
drink here
alright that's gross you don't hear
anybody chewing gum or [ __ ] take a
sip of anything but you know what it's
hot as [ __ ] out here I was playing drums
all day I was actually playing with
other human beings if you can believe it
it's a whole different kind of drumming
you know when you play by yourself and
you do whatever [ __ ] you want you screw
up there's nobody looking over their
shoulder like really you said you could
play drums there's nobody looking at you
like that so it was a whole different
[ __ ] level anyways alright sometime
some but the social network said they're
like clubs you know what I mean where
you got the new hot club and all the
cool kids are going there and then all
the Nerds show up and the Bridge and
Tunnel crowd and all that [ __ ] and then
everybody took off to Facebook that's
what the [ __ ] happened and then all the
nerds went over there and then all the
cool kids went over to Twitter and now
all the nerds are following them over
there and it just it's gonna be never
[ __ ] ending so that's why I'm still
here on MySpace I like it it's a quiet
bar now you know they can put the game
on I could sit here sipping my drink
having a good [ __ ] time done all
these crazy kids you know it's like a
dive that's why I like my space it's
like a dive bar right now you know no
okay
maybe it isn't maybe I'm just a [ __ ]
loser it really is just a vast waste
line here I'm not gonna lie to you I
just
it's just [ __ ] and musicians that's
all that's left here and one lonely
comedian alright let's get to some
feedback here this is from a woman from
a couple weeks ago when I was trashing
that Carrie Underwood song she said I am
a woman and I've recently become a
regular listener to your podcast I was
listening to your July 6th podcast and
laughed uncontrollably I actually like I
actually liked that Carrie Underwood
song and cannot argue with the things
you said
two piece combination to the cabbage
comment was frickin hilarious just
thought you should hear it from a woman
that was awesome all right well you know
what I should well because thank you
very much I appreciate that and just
because you brought that up I'm gonna
actually give you the history behind the
two-piece combination to the cabbage
actually where I heard that it was
actually a sleigh I gave a variation of
it I was on my way to do a stand-up gig
in one of the outer boroughs in New York
and I was with somebody and they were
pissed at somebody else and they were
saying how they were going to kill him
and they were not joking and they were
going off and just like you know this
[ __ ] this is my [ __ ] dad I'm
gonna [ __ ] abolish it and he was
basically and I'm looking at the do cuz
he really you know you know some people
say I'm gonna [ __ ] kill this guy this
guy was dead serious so it was kind of
an awkward moment you know I'm just sort
of like nod and you know trying to act
like I hear somebody every day tell me
that they're gonna kill another human
being and he was talking about he's
gonna shoot him in the head and he the
way he put it he said granite I hadn't
laughed up to this point he said he was
gonna shoot him in the head and then
there was this awkward silence and then
he just says a throwaway throwaway line
he just it he said two beans to the
cabbage and it was like a half second
pause and I just started roaring
laughing which got him laughing and then
we would just [ __ ] laughing and then
he kept trying to say no I'm serious son
as he's [ __ ] laughing and it was just
one of those great [ __ ] moments and
nobody ended up getting killed at the
end of it and it was just something
that's just stuck it's not the beans
it's the cabbage there's just something
there's something about when you do
damage to somebody's head that it
literally cabbage is the I don't know
why it's just perfect it's just perfect
so that's how I got the cabbage
reference
and of course everyone was for me I
didn't tell you the burro see right
there that's how you do it
what the [ __ ] of my kid and if anything
ever happened and they dragged me and
they wouldn't have to do good cop bad
cop all they'd have to do is slam the
door I'd be like okay we were driving on
the OIE and anyways already here's a
[ __ ] up news story for you uh [ __ ]
goddamn piece of [ __ ] computer or maybe
it's the person operating it alright
here we go he's a [ __ ] up news story
that somebody sent me a lacrosse woman
now this is not a woman who plays
lacrosse it's a woman from a town
evidently called lacrosse and this story
so [ __ ] up that I actually researched
it on the Internet and by research I
mean I did a quick search and I clicked
on the first story and it agreed with me
and therefore it became fact so with
that background let's read the story all
right now lacrosse woman a woman from
lacrosse is accused of stabbing her
boyfriend Tuesday after she caught him
watching pornography and masturbating
according to La Crosse police reports
okay she caught him watching pornography
and masturbating so she allegedly
stabbed him
Rachel Ferrara 23 found her 24 year-old
boyfriend inside her home the couple
argued and Ferrara accused the man of
explicative being a an exploitive
cheater being a [ __ ] cheater because
evidently he was masturbating to
pornography she evidently punched him
twice in the abdomen kicked him in the
groin Ferrara then back the man into the
kitchen which I know a lot of people
like that a woman couldn't back a man
and yes she can because we cannot lay a
hand on you so when you go psycho that's
what you do you back into the room going
honey relax relax crazy you take a
couple more you know but you try to do
the George for me you know George
Foreman covers up his body late in his
career
you got the one for I'm so it in front
of your face and the other one below you
it's almost like you're starting to
cross your arms to do that Run DMC thing
but you stop Midway you
like the end of chips um anyways god
bless you if he got that joke alright so
for our then back the man into the
kitchen she grabbed a five inch serrated
knife and slashed his arms before
stabbing him in the abdomen according to
reports she reportedly refused his
attempts to calm down calm her down and
she screamed at him to leave the man
drove himself to Gundersen blood uh
Medical Center where he was treated and
released
the woman Ferrara was arrested on
charges of disorderly conduct while
armed and recklessly endangering safety
she's expected later today in La Crosse
County Circuit Court so the man who sent
me this said really disorderly conduct
while armed and recklessly endangering
safety if I as a guy went and stabbed my
girlfriend in the abdomen because she
had a vibrator in her [ __ ] I would get
charged with attempted murder and
possibly rape but I guess that's why we
make $1 more an hour
oh [ __ ] that I just steal one of your
jokes oh well sincerely and then he
names the name of a comedian who's known
for stealing jokes yeah that is kind of
a light charge wouldn't you say you know
I'm not sitting here saying that she
actually did any of this [ __ ] because I
understand that when I know what alleged
means okay but my thing is what you know
if she did do this [ __ ] which they're
trying to prove disorderly conduct while
armed and recklessly endangering safety
now what does that mean to you guys okay
if I told you I was arrested of
disorderly conduct while armed and
recklessly endangering safety you know
what that would mean that would mean I'm
at a gun range and I'm shit-faced and I
didn't properly holster my weapon after
I shot at a paper target that's kind of
what it seems like you know or maybe I'm
doing something you know I'm trying to
shoot a ball of rocket out of my [ __ ]
or solder
I don't know what you know what I mean
but that we would you know if I told you
I got arrested for that [ __ ] you
wouldn't thought that I [ __ ] stabbed
somebody you know slash their arms and
then [ __ ] stab them
you know I don't understand
when is the world going to understand
that whoever is wielding a knife if they
stab somebody you know regardless of
their sex that is attempted murder isn't
it
it's [ __ ] unreal I gotta tell you
something I'm gonna go see that movie
coming out
I think it's called orphan I don't know
what with that little scary girl in it
well they they they had they rescue this
girl like some [ __ ] psycho pit bull
like the one that I have oh my god she
had a [ __ ] dream the other night and
[ __ ] you you dude from England alright
you fast-forward through this [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ] I do from a couple
weeks ago says he can't stand my stories
about I'm gonna [ __ ] tell one every
week just to annoy you
this is how crazy shelter dogs are my
[ __ ] dog is lying there and I'm about
and I'm like you know drifting off to
sleep and all of a sudden I'm hearing
like right and it's like seeping into my
dream you know I'm [ __ ] I don't know
talking to some [ __ ] in my dream and
all of a sudden she turns into like a
bear or some [ __ ] right so I [ __ ]
wake up and like [ __ ] kind of dream is
that I look over and there's my damn dog
sound asleep moving one of his paws
going over doing that [ __ ] so I don't
know what the [ __ ] to do right you know
you're not supposed to wake a sleeping
sleepwalking human being what do I do
with a [ __ ] psycho pit bull that's
evidently having words with somebody in
a goddamn dream so I decided to wake her
up I was like Cleo Cleo Cleo and then
she immediately just sort of woke up and
then looked at me and just started
wagging her tail like oh hey how's it
going and then just put her head back
down again like all that [ __ ] just
didn't happen it's just [ __ ]
[ __ ] thing's nuts all right let's get
back to the let's get back I want to see
that movie that movie orphan there which
is you know it's got just there's
something about women when they're the
bad guy it's extra scary to me
you know we saw about a guy being a
maniac I don't you just look at it I
have [ __ ] that guy
[ __ ] him I you know whatever I dropkick
them you know you just think [ __ ] like
that for the most part but there's
something about I don't know if it's
they've always freaked me out and for
some reason you know I was thinking
about that how like women you know women
being the the Michael Myers to me is way
more scary than the guy and I remember
when I way back in like 82 or 83 when I
first got cable I was watching late
night and I can't even you know I I
really feel bad for people of this
generation who have just grown up with
cable you have no idea how [ __ ]
insane
cable is you have no idea we have three
networks two UHF s and that was it and
nobody curse no titties no nothing it
was it was unbelievable unbelievable
when that [ __ ] came out so anyways so
I'm watching late night and I was
watching this movie and I looked it up
on YouTube it's actually the movie is
called curtains and it has one of the
most bizarre fucked-up scene so now I
went back and I watched it it really
didn't hold up over time but back in the
day it really [ __ ] freaked me out
if basically there's a scene in that
movie curtains where there's a girl
who's out on a pond and she's [ __ ]
take I can't even explain it first I
forget because I'm seeing the moving so
long the clip I watched she's basically
uncovering snow and you think it's a
dead body but it's a doll underneath and
she's holding it up the doll has a weird
look on her face and then they're sort
of cutting to these [ __ ] ice skates
slowly in slow motion just because
to skate across the pond towards this
girl and of course she has no idea that
this [ __ ] thing is coming towards her
and they just show it from a distance
and it just looks like a person and as
it gets closer and closer yeah it just
it's this [ __ ] psycho I I think it's
a woman I can't even remember but it
looks like a woman it's got a female
face like a witch face with long hair
and she's skating like she's speed skate
and then she pulls out like this [ __ ]
sickle
I can't exceed it's [ __ ] up right I
mean I don't know dude I went from
Barney Miller to that that was that's
what it was like to have no cable and
then to have that and I'm like literally
1213 [ __ ] years old the movies called
curtains just look it up it's the only
part of the movie probably weren't worth
watching you can actually watch the clip
and when you're when you're there
there's another clip that you have to
watch that kind of ties into this whole
thing where women you know when they do
violent [ __ ] they just don't get charged
with the same stuff that a guy does and
if you really feel that there's no
justice in the world ever when it comes
to females physically doing stuff - guys
I have a video for you and I cannot take
credit for this YouTube video this isn't
even YouTube video of the week it's not
YouTube video of the month as far as I'm
concerned this is YouTube video of the
[ __ ] year this is what I want you
guys to google right here go whatever go
on YouTube and search tough-talking
college girl alright somebody sent me
this clip if this unbelievable okay and
toughest spell tu FF okay and if
basically Enzo balls the classic
scenario the hot chick in the bikini
there's some guy hitting on her she
starts giving him [ __ ] back he gives her
[ __ ] and then she throws a drink in his
face you know and then turns around and
walks away
cuz that's what you do when you throw a
[ __ ] drink in somebody's face you
just walk away you know now as a guy I
feel bad for guys who ever [ __ ]
listen to this right now and you're not
you're a [ __ ] computer cuz you really
just need to watch it you've really need
to watch it cuz in a perfect world this
is what you'd be able to do as a guy
alright now I don't I have to talk about
this video i you know spoiler alert i'm
gonna tell you what the [ __ ] happens so
if you want to hit pause and [ __ ]
watch the video or if you want to listen
to me talk about the video this is I'm
babbling right now to give you that
opportunity okay cuz I'm gonna ruin what
the [ __ ] happens okay I'm gonna talk
about it in three two one
alright here we go so she throws the
[ __ ] drink in his face and just turns
around and walks away okay cuz that's
what happens in movies nothing ever
happens and not to mention if you ever
do go to make a move on some girl who
does some [ __ ] like that to you these
usually a couple bounces there to choke
you out
basically the scenario is they're
outside at a pool you know I can't
defend the kid who got the drink thrown
in his face he definitely kind of looks
like he could be a bit of a douche but
whatever he's got the balls to walk up
to this hot chick that back in the day
when I was his age I wouldn't have the
balls to walk up to so I give the kid
props okay but he does have his
sunglasses dangling from his ears and
hanging underneath his chin so right
there the douche level of that guy's
pretty [ __ ] high so whatever so she
throws the [ __ ] drink in his face and
just walks away
you know she doesn't give a [ __ ] that
he's got to go home and change or he's
got to stand there and be sticky and
80-degree weather outside the [ __ ]
the pool so he immediately you know
takes a half a pause and then just
[ __ ] walks up to the girl and she's
still trying to act tough she's like
what you know you know like when white
girls because they've watched reality TV
now know how to act ghetto she's like
what and throws the empty plastic cup
down on the ground like she's gonna do
something alright and the dude I thought
he was gonna wind up and blast her in
the face so at this point I'm watching
it with one eye cuz I don't give a [ __ ]
what a girl does you never want to see
her get his [ __ ] closed fisted it's
it's just it's ugly even though she
threw the drink but the dude [ __ ]
just I had to watch it twice to see what
he does he does a [ __ ] leg sweep that
that I swear to God
he could have beat one of the Gracie's
with one of his fight he just it's like
the girls standing up and then she is
not he just I can't believe like from
her knees down both those parts of her
legs didn't fly off like a mortar hit
him that's how [ __ ] he just [ __ ] I
mean literally standing up acting it out
again huh this is like when I told the
Rose Bowl story back in the day right he
literally just [ __ ] leg sweeps her
and she just goes right down on the
ground and she hits the back of her head
in the concrete and that's the part we
like ooh not good funny until the back
of the head hits the concrete but she
immediately goes like oh my god
screaming basically sounding the alarm
for all the guys to come and rescue her
which they kind of don't they kind of
all stand up like hey dude whoa what's
going on you know and I know you know
why did I try to describe that I can't
do justice you have to see this
tough-talking college girl just Google
that and spell Tufte uff and I swear to
God like I said I don't advocate hitting
a woman and I think women should respect
that rather than take advantage of it
and I really think if you take a full
drink and you throw it in somebody's
face you're really taking advantage of
that a man should never hit a woman okay
and I really have to be honest with you
if the guy punched her in the face I
would have said he was a douche but
there's something about a leg sweep that
it had a gentleman quality to it you
know in fact that's the comment I left
under the first time the video was
update was taken down but the comment I
left was leg sweep equals gentleman I
[Laughter]
gotta be honest with you
I've seen girls get punched I've seen
them get slapped okay I've seen a guy
shake a girl I've seen a dude choke a
girl none of this I advocate but I've
seen all that I have never seen somebody
go for the leg sweep and it was it was a
it was a it was surprising you know what
I mean it's like when you see it moving
you think you know how it's gonna end
like I'll Jesus and then the hero comes
in on the white horse and then now
now Leonardo DiCaprio gets popped in the
[ __ ] elevator and you're like holy
[ __ ]
holy [ __ ] I didn't see that coming
that's what that's what that [ __ ]
legsweep was like it was like seeing
DiCaprio get popped in the departed
[ __ ] phenomenal YouTube video of the
year why don't we have that that's a new
segment here on my Monday morning
podcast let's let's have nominees okay
cuz when they nominate the Oscars it's
usually like two three months ahead of
time that's all I have in December you
guys just remind me we will have the
nominees for YouTube video of the year
for me okay
that movie is like the equivalent to
that I'm not gonna say there will be
blood it's more like No Country for Old
Men you know that kid should just had a
bowl cut and just not blinked when he
[ __ ] did it and and that I would have
bought it on DVD all right so there you
go okay was that misogynistic enough we
always have to have that moment in this
[ __ ] podcast all right let's wind it
down here with the questions because
it's getting late and I got to get up
early here cuz I have a tee time a [ __ ]
and you stepped on the bull alright
questions
hey mr. burr how's that for making you
feel [ __ ] old it did it did make me
feel alright alright I was just
wondering what your thoughts on were on
why people are so easily offended
especially by foul language I thought
you might have some insight here as
someone who uses the word [ __ ] and [ __ ]
quite regularly ain't guilty as charged
maybe it has something to do with the
fact that I live in the south but it
seems like you drop the f-bomb here oh I
see what you're saying maybe it has to
do with the fact that I live in the
south that if you drop the f-bomb here
or tell someone tell someone with all
all the [ __ ] padding
why didn't I enlarges I am the worst
reader I'm sorry guys let me start this
again
maybe I something to do with the fact
that I live in the south but it seems
like if you dropped the f-bomb here or
tell tell something to someone without
all the [ __ ] padding and they just
lose their
[ __ ] do you think this has something to
do with the [ __ ] vacation of America or
do most people just grow up in a
household where ballbusting oh do most
people not grow up in a household where
ball busting is commonplace I don't know
you know when I go across America I
don't see a lot of [ __ ] I see a lot
of psychos I just think in general that
this country has you know just really
they've become corporate and they cast a
wide net
they're always commercial fishing so
they're trying not to offend people so a
lot of the shows on TV have sort of been
dumbed down I think but in general I
mean I live in America and I say [ __ ]
[ __ ] all the time as do all of my
friends and there you go
so I'm defining America by how I behave
I don't know I think I think certain
people grow up with ballbusting and
other people don't and the reality is
everybody has a different line and I
think the real thing is that people who
get offended are way more organized and
they complain and they write letters and
people who don't give a [ __ ] don't give
a [ __ ] enough to write a letter to say I
don't give a [ __ ]
you know so there you go did you guys
hear that burp that was one of those
internal burps that I heard in my head
and I can't tell if that was out loud
all right um all right let's move on to
the next one hey Bill big fan love you
Kennedy and you purchased a [ __ ]
hilarious thank you very much I
appreciate it you don't feel free thank
you anyways I have a question for you
when a comedian such as yourself records
a CD or a DVD is that a one-time shot or
are you able to reshoot if you are
unhappy with the show it all depends I
like in for the most part yeah if you do
like a stand-up special you do you do at
least two shows I was watching a guy
recently on HBO - his special and he was
talking about working somewhere in Texas
and he was going to do four shows and
from the four shows he was going to put
together the special but for
most part you do at least two so this is
how it's worked with me I did a CD
called emotionally unavailable which is
available on iTunes I really need to
[ __ ] out my [ __ ] more to by the way but
how I did that was I taped that at the
laughs house in Philadelphia and I was
doing four shows two Friday
and two saturday and i taked all the
shows I listened back to all the shows
and I just like the second show Saturday
night and I liked it and I got heckled
and there was some awkward moments in it
and it just sounded like a show and what
I liked about the old school comedy
albums that I used to listen to when I
was growing up as you really felt like
you were kind of in the nightclub and
you were listening and that type of
thing and it just I don't know with all
this pro tool stuff you can really make
something sound really slick and I you
know I think I wrote that in the liner
notes why I'm really going back a long
way I think the liner notes actually
wrote like I didn't kind of want to
splice together a performance that never
really happened you know so and then the
other half was I was [ __ ] lazy and it
was true I wasn't going to go through
four hours of [ __ ] audio and just
listening to me do the same just
couldn't [ __ ] do it cells like you
know what I like that second show
Saturday so that's how I did that that
one on the HBO one when I did my half
hour there was two tapings and my first
show went really well so I knew I had a
good special and then I came out the
second one and the second one I was even
more loose and that one just went
ridiculously great and afterwards the
director was like you know what I think
that second one was the one other than
this one little joke so why don't we
just take one little joke from the first
one stick that in and the rest will be
the second show and I said works for me
so that's how that one went together and
why do I do this was only one show that
one and that was because of the budget
we kind of waited a little too long to
get a theatre and we had to spend more
money than we thought and
in the end we only had the budget to do
one of them so what you see is what you
get on that one that was just one one
take and I left out some tags and that
type of [ __ ] and it was kind of freaking
me out in the beginning of the special
if you look closely in my eyes you'll
see it a couple of times but then I was
just like well [ __ ] it no one's gonna
know that I missed the tags you know
this is the special bill why don't you
get present and [ __ ] deliver it so I
just you know yeah that's how I did that
one but uh yeah basically speaking yeah
you don't just do one unless you have no
[ __ ] budget or you [ __ ] up your
budget or something like that so this
one that I do in San Diego San Diego in
San Francisco I am going to be doing two
and also I'm gonna be doing a bunch of
[ __ ] road work before before I come
up to it so I'm gonna be extra ready and
I actually learned something last time
when I did an hour basically when I did
my half-hour for HBO was on the road
doing 50 minutes so to do a half hour
was a joke it's kind of like if you're
doing cardio for 50 minutes and then one
day did 30 be easy so but what I wasn't
doing when I trained for the hour was
when I was doing the hour I was doing
right about an hour so it felt like more
work than doing the half hour so this
time when I go through I'm going to be
doing at least an hour and ten and an
hour and 15 minutes when I'm on stage
especially September September October
November unless I'm doing three shows at
night I won't do that because I don't
want to back it up I don't hey you know
baía actually I am actually really
against doing more than an hour on stage
I think it becomes you know people are
just like alright and we got it you're
funny we have to go to work tomorrow
okay my face hurts it's like you're
overselling I always feel like when you
do more than an hour you're kind of
overselling although I did an hour and
13 I just uploaded that one from San
Francisco not what you guys can listen
where I can listen to it and it actually
holds together I think maybe I just
wasn't in shape enough to do it but I
just untied
fine you know once you get like an hour
hour and 15 it's like dude enough enough
all right Jesus Christ bill I mean
[ __ ] different ways you're gonna
answer that
all right overrated underrated then I'm
gonna get out of here okay
underrated Bilborough Thank You Louis
black Don Cheadle Samuel Jackson beer
real hip hop in parentheses common mos
def Talib Kweli Kweli I don't know what
the [ __ ] that is ACK yeah he is
underrated I have no idea that Kanye
West
how are the [ __ ] is Kanye West
underrated overrated everything on be et
MTV vh1 Sonia Sotomayor I don't know who
that is Barack Obama United States
military I was a marine for five years
Jay [ __ ] Cutler that still won't help
the Bears for [ __ ] you know actually
reminds me you know something I finally
you know I've gotten into some sort of
old school like hip-hop but I just don't
know what the [ __ ] to listen to I'm kind
of talking like late 80s early 90s
anything pre biggie if he can if he got
some [ __ ] you know and not just obvious
[ __ ] that like kool Moe Dee that they
played on like MTV like some underground
[ __ ] like this is stuff that I always
hear a big all you know I kind of like
this guy Lee big oh he was in leaders of
the new school or who's that group Arif
sermon was in you know like if you know
any of that [ __ ] if you can let me know
give me the heads up on that I'd like
I'd like to download some of that [ __ ]
cuz I don't know I'm into it now I'm
trying to play drums to it and that's
fine again for a challenging all right
another underrated comics overrated
here's an overrated one this is what
kind of an obscure one comp overrated
comics who do a visual bit during their
specials and acknowledge to the live
audience how funny it is that the CD
listeners are left out you made a funny
face we get it yeah you know what I
think I've done that or you're recording
a CD and you do a visual joke and then
you comment how heaven
at home isn't gonna understand that joke
yeah we're all doing it alright um last
thing ask bill hey Bill just started
listening to uninformed last week
and that's my radio show that I do on
Sirius satellite radio sirius XM
whatever the [ __ ] they call it and you
know what somebody just sent me a
[ __ ] thing here on where the hell you
could listen to those bill read this you
[ __ ] this is like the new thing
everyone's doing cuz that one guy
uninformed here we go alright here's
where you can listen to all the
uninformed shows that that I've done
with Joe DeRosa for free um you can on
mini-mini nova comm mi n I Minnie mi ni
Nova and OVA all lowercase no spaces
calm there you go you can listen to all
of them and we're gonna start doing them
again we had one here in July I don't
know when the [ __ ] they even put it out
and [ __ ] disappointing how
disorganized we are with that show but
anyways let's get to a spell here bill
just started us two uninformed week ago
I downloaded a package of all the shows
done to date hence the ancient reference
anyways you know cuz I said no XM anyway
you mentioned a while ago that you're
really socially awkward as a kid I'd
love to hear how you overcame that I
dropped out of high school at 16 and it
seems the more time I spent alone the
harder it gets to inject myself into any
situation that involves other human
beings I'm now 221 apparently an adult
but anytime I have to have to do a task
that may involve other people it's a
real problem even simple things like
taking out the garbage are going grocery
shopping make me shake and sweat my
situation is probably more severe than
yours was but I'd love to hear any
advice to to overcome this nonsense
alright
okay well alright what can I start with
that [ __ ] this is
all right here's how bad mine was I I
was literally I would like be at an ATM
and if someone was standing behind me
and I had two transactions I would only
do one and I would get out of line for
fear that the person behind me the
second I started the second transaction
would literally beat the [ __ ] out of me
okay now all this [ __ ] is going on in my
head because that's how it worked on my
family growing up you know if you took
too much time mixing I a bunch of
brothers so we end up fist fighting but
until you verbalize it out loud you
don't realize how [ __ ] ridiculous it
is and so I don't know what did I do
I basically well to become a comedian I
was in college at the time and what I
did was I knew that I could barely give
a book report without my face turning
beet red so what I did was I just
started taking classes classes where I
knew I'd have to get up in front of the
class and the more I did it the more I
enjoyed it and the more it just it felt
awesome so what I would do is I don't
know I get out a piece of paper write
out what your fear is like what do you
what are you thinking is going to happen
that's another thing to men you'll spend
your whole life cowering over this great
fear that only exists in your [ __ ]
head and I swear to God and that is most
times it's just for some [ __ ] that
happened when you were a kid and your
brain was forming how it was gonna view
the world and you just saw some [ __ ] or
some [ __ ] happen to you at the wrong
[ __ ] time and then that [ __ ] just
becomes law in your head as like a
five-year-old
you know and you're literally 21 years
old making dis fearful decisions of a
five-year-old and believe me do it I did
that and I can tell you this you know
you're young enough we it's kind of easy
to undo that [ __ ] but if you wait later
in life like I kind of did with a lot of
stuff what it is is that little seed of
a [ __ ] up thought kind of grows into
this big [ __ ] oak tree that you got a
hack down so what I would do is you know
I don't know what the [ __ ] can you do I
don't know what I don't know what you do
for a living I would you know try to be
more social at work
to shoot the [ __ ] get involved in
something if you're good at sports join
a softball league if you play an
instrument start jamming with other
people you got to get yourself into the
mix of people and you know it's kind of
like you know I knew somebody who really
sucked at driving you know and they were
freaking out about it and just sorta you
know the more they did it it's just like
stand up if you swear to God I would
never show you guys these tapes but if
you could ever see video of when I first
started doing stand-up when I got on
stage I was so [ __ ] nervous
I never stopped moving the whole time I
was on stage I will get on stage and I
would just paste the entire thing and I
would be pouring sweat it's like it's
almost like performance art or some
avant-garde cuz it doesn't even [ __ ]
make sense when you watch it I can't
believe I ever even got any laughs but
as he you know years went by and the
more shows I did the more comfortable I
got the more presence I could be and
that's basically how to do it but don't
be tough on yourself just know you're
gonna bomb the same way I bombed as a
comedian and I don't know find humor in
your shortcomings you know and just keep
working on it and you know believe me
dude you're not just gonna start talking
to somebody in the next day you're not
gonna be you know shy or whatever so
give you give yourself permission to
[ __ ] up for a while as you work your way
through it don't do this [ __ ] where you
kind of say half a sentence and then you
get freaked out and then you stop and
then the person is looking at you like
what the [ __ ] and then you feel like a
douche and then you don't try it again
until the next decade that's not the way
to go
alright 21 you should be out there
drinking you should be out there banging
[ __ ] [ __ ] and having a good time
because someday you're gonna get married
and even if you have a great marriage
the level of responsibility and the
taxes and what the [ __ ] bankers do to
you your life is gonna suck so yeah you
can do it dude don't don't don't don't
[ __ ] just don't be too hard on
yourself that's the biggest thing when
you're trying to learn new [ __ ] just
know give yourself permission to suck
out at the beginning and then BAM there
you go how's that there's a nice feel
good way to end this podcast you know I
started off the [ __ ] was I talking about
coffee
Golf and then leg sweeping a chick you
know with looks like it was gonna go off
the rails and look at it ended very
nicely see I'm not all bad am i all
right there you go
well there's your podcast for this week
I hope you guys enjoyed it you guys have
a wonderful week and if you're into the
the Denver area hell if you're in
Cheyenne Wyoming why don't you drive
down and come down to my show and I was
just gonna say I'll have a drink with
you but I can't I got a [ __ ] C I
gotta stay on point here I'll have a
sarsaparilla with you I think I'll be
doing like [ __ ] cranberry juice and
lime is that what the [ __ ] I'm gonna do
huh Jesus it's gonna be [ __ ] brutal
all right you guys have a good week and
that is all hate and the new segment is
that nominees for YouTube clip of the
year I'm able to do other month whatever
we'll work it out as we do it alright
guys
alright have a good week take it easy
you